За три години їзди від метушливого Берліна
розташоване село, де люди намагаються жити
в цілковитій гармонії з природою
Селище називається Сім Лип
Як їм це вдається?
Перше, що необхідно зробити після прибуття,
залишити машину на парковці
Село - вільна від автомобілів зона
Дивно, що мешканці села
взагалі користуються автівками
Я саме намагаюся зателефонувати
одному з мешканців села
але нічого не виходить
Слухавку домашнього телефону ніхто не бере
а мобілок більшість з тутешніх не мають
А люди, які сюди приїздять, як я,
мусять вимкнути свої ґаджети
Екологічне село налічує близько 150 мешканців
Його заснували 20 років тому
Приміром, Міхаель приїхав сюди з Ганновера
Що мені найбільше заважало в місті -
це транспортний рух та реклама.
Також відчуття, що ти безсилий проти цього
Ми намагаємося продемонструвати
що в центрі Німеччини
можна жити не завдаючи шкоди довкіллю
Ми живемо добре попри те
що витрачаємо значно менше енергії, ніж деінде
Стіни будинків ізольовані соломою,
це заощаджує енергію
Струм значною мірою виробляється тут же
в селі, ним же обігрівають воду
Одна з найкрутіших речей тут -
ось цей компостний туалет
У ньому немає змиву
Після того, як справили нужду, це відразу компостується і перетворюється на добриво
Цікаво, що тут не смердить, бо добре провітрюється
Це мене справді вразило
Екологічне село не лише енергоефективне
Жителі намагаються також самостійно забезпечувати себе продуктами харчування
Насіння - екологічно чисте. Жодних хімічних добрив
Поля та сади обробляють переважно вручну
Це екологічніше, і це логічніше -
працювати без машин
Це краще для ґрунту, для довкілля,
менше бензину, смороду тощо
Навесні, влітку - чудово спостерігати за тим,
як усе росте, розвивається
Почуваєшся ближче до природи, до життя
При температурі плюс 35 у тіні, як сьогодні,
це нелегка праця
Тваринництва тут немає
Цих лам утримують виключно як домашніх тварин
М'яса під час спільних трапез немає
Це надто шкідливо для довкілля
Але також тому, що управління селом
взяли у свої руки вегани
Близько 70 відсотків овочів селяни вирощують самі
І планують ще більше
*Ням*
Ммм, це, мабуть, найздоровіша їжа,
яку я коли-небудь їла
Рештки їжі також компостують -
адже це теж ресурси
Надмірне споживання жителі села засуджують
Певні продукти вважають необхідними
решту - розцінюють як непотрібну розкіш
Придбати їх можна в єдиному сільському магазині
Ціни кусючі - зрештою все, що тут продається, - екологічно чисте
А це - має свою ціну
Зате у подарунковому куточку - все безкоштовно
Селяни зносять сюди непотрібний одяг або інші речі
Більшість мешканців забезпечують себе,
працюючи просто в селі
на адміністративних посадах, як майстри чи садівники
Тобто гроші, так би мовити, залишаються в селі
Утім, дозволити собі таке екологічно свідоме життя
може далеко не кожен
навіть у Німеччині, не кажучи вже у світі
Аби стати членом цієї громади, необхідно сплатити до сільської каси 12 тисяч євро